DOCTOR WEBER NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT
ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP MEN [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
LONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER GARCIA.
BUT WATER GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GROW GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
HIGHLY KEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
SUSHI [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REYES THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER X..
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. TWO WEEKS AGO OUR
OWN HOTELS FOR CUDA WHO WILL BE
A HUNDRED IN TWO YEARS OLD IN ME.
FELL AND BROKE HIS FEMUR.
AT HIS ADVANCED AGE HE UNDERWENT
A PARTIAL HIP REPLACEMENT
SURGERY.
WE CONTINUE TO BE WITH HIM DALY
IN HE IS NOW IN REHAB.
IMPRESSING HIS THERAPISTS WITH
HIS RESILIENCE AND DETERMINATION.
WHEN ONE LIVES TO SUCH AN
ADVANCE AGE PEOPLE OFTEN SAY?
HE'S LIVED A GOOD LIFE SHE'S
LIVED A GOOD A FULL LIFE.
BUT A FULL LIFE.
IS NOT A LIFE FULL OF HAPPINESS
AND FULFILLMENT.
A FULL LIFE IS TO HAVE LIVED THE
FULL SPECTRUM OF LIFE
EXPERIENCES.
IS TO HAVE LIVE KNOWING GREAT
JOY FULFILLMENT AND LOVE.
BUT ALSO KNOWING DEEP SADNESS
FOSTER PROSTRATION EN LOS --
FULL LIFE IS WHEN THEY HAVE SEEN
THE CYCLE OF LIFE BEGIN AND END
AGAIN AND AGAIN LIKE THE EVER
CHANGING SEASONS.
ALTHOUGH VERY FEW ARE ABLE TO
LIVE TO BE A HUNDRED INTO WE CAN
ALL STILL LIVE A FULL LIFE.
WE NEED ONLY EMBRACE EACH NEW
DAY TRYING IN WAYS GREAT AND
SMALL TO TOUCH THE WORLD AROUND
US WITH CARING AND KINDNESS.
WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO LIVE A
HUNDRED IN TWO YEARS BUT WE CAN
TRY TO MAKE A MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE WITH THE TIME WE HAVE.
THE UNFORGETTABLE TENNIS
CHAMPION ARTHUR ASHE DID JUSTICE.
HE TOUCHED THE WORLD AROUND HIM
IN WAYS GREAT AND SMALL WITH
CARING AND KINDNESS.
OF LIFE HE ONCE SAID.
THEBEST WAY TO JUDGE YOUR LIFE
IS TO ASK YOURSELF DID I MAKE
THE BEST USE OF THE TIME I HAD.
ARTHUR ASHE.
AT SAID THAT HE WANTED TO BE
REMEMBERED FOR MORE THAN JUST
HIS ATHLETIC ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
HE LIVED HIS FORTY NINE YEARS
WITH KAREN PURPOSE AND HIS
LEGACY OF INSPIRATION HAS
ANSWERED HIS QUESTION REGARDING
LIFE.
THIS ALSO MAKE THE BEST USE OF
THE TIME WE HAVE. TO MAKE A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN THE
WORLD.
NO MORE MEN DOWN SUIT WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PUT
YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART
[inaudible] EIGHT BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE --
THE OUR THANK YOU YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY FEBRUARY ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IS ONLY ABOUT
AT ONE PM THE ANA WILL COVER
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING TO CLERK THE
DAWSON WAS IN THE DEATHS OF
SYSTEM AVAILABLE WHEN READING.
THE ROLL CALL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AND FRAWLEY'S SIMPLY
MOTION CARRY TIME WHEN A WAR PM
SPEAKER PRO TEM TO RECORD A SONG
IN OUR SCHOOLS DOORS WERE IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
LISTENER BONTA MOVES.
MR LACKEY SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MOVING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAM GRAY. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA --
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN.
AND FOR A FUNERAL.
A DEATH IN THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN AA.
AND ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BY
BAUER-KAHAN CHOI KANSEN CHU COM
LONGER DIE OF AND MEDINA. TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MISTER SPEAKER ARE FOR THE
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN TING AND
DAVID CHIU TO SPEAK.
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME VERY
SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TANG MEMBERS.
MISTER KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
HONORED.
TO RECOGNIZE THE FOURTH GRADE
CLASS FROM THE JOSE ORTEGA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHICH IS WHEN
MY DAUGHTER WENT TO ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TO REALLY WANT TO WELCOME
ALL THE FOURTH GRADERS FROM.
JOSE ORTEGA
.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
BESTER CHIU YOU HAVE GAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND AND COLLEAGUES ARE I RISE
TODAY TO INTRODUCE THE WILCOX
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL TEAM FROM
SANTA CLARA CALIFORNIA OF COURSE --
IN THE TWENTY FIRST --
ASSEMBLY TO FREE FOR WINNING D.
C. I. F. DIVISION THREE A STATE
CHAMPION.
AT THAT THIS IS THE FIRST STATE
HYDRO ONE BY THE WELL **** HIGH
SCHOOL SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN DURING THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SEASON WILCOX
HIGH SCHOOL FINISH THE SEASON
WAS AN OUTSTANDING FOURTEEN TO
ONE RECORD.
AND WENT UNDEFEATED.
IN THE TNC --
LEAGUE DURING THE REGULAR SEASON
GAMES.
A VERY INTERESTING FACT ABOUT
THE YEAR CHAMPIONSHIP BEING IS
THAT WELL **** HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL TEAM DID NOT A TâM A
SINGLE PASS IN THE ENTIRE GAME.
INSTEAD.
THE GENE RUN FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR YARDS ON THE GROUND TO WIN
SAYS STATE CHAMPIONSHIP VICTORY.
WAS THERE WITH ALL OF MANY HOURS
OF TRAINING DETERMINATION AND
TEAMWORK BY ALL THE PLAYERS AND
THE COACHES.
THEY YOU CAME A LONG WAY AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEASON THEY
WERE RANKED.
FORTY THREE AND AND THERE'D BE
BUT THEY END UP WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP SO I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE HEAD COACH AND
THE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR.
PAUL ROSA AND THE WHOLE A
CHARGERS TEAM.
I'D LIKE TO ESPECIALLY
CONGRATULATE THE SENIORS ON THE
FOOTBALL TEAM FOR THE AREA
TREMENDOUS ACHIEVEMENT THIS YEAR.
AND COMPETING YOUR FOUR YEARS OF
HIGH SCHOOL AS THE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
WE WISH YOU A GREAT SUCCESS IN
YOUR FUTURE ENDEAVORS. TO ALL
THE STUDENTS RETURNING NEXT YEAR.
HAVE A GREAT SCHOOL YEAR ON AND
OFF THE FIELD.
AND WE ALL WISH TO CELEBRATE
THIS AGAIN NEXT YEAR.
TODAY ON THE FLOOR I AM PROUD TO
WELCOME WILCOX HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL CODES FOUR ROESER.
PRINCIPLE CHRISTINE GONZALEZ
PAYING CAP TURNS.
GAVE HER A I SEC.
SAT.
PAUL ROESER.
IN AROUND.
A BEING A PAIN SAY.
AND TALK TO A STAND ROASTED
SUPERINTENDENT OF US I RIGHT.
ALONG WITH ALL THE OF PROUD
PARENTS WILL MAKE THIS LONG
DRIVE TO SACRAMENTO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MAYES POWER QUE HAN FROM MY DESK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF ISRAEL TO THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST THE HONORABLE SHLOMI
KAUFMAN.
SINCE HIS ASSIGNMENT IN SAN
FRANCISCO BEGAN IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS
SKILLED AND EXPERIMENT
EXPERIENCED DIPLOMAT.
PRIOR TO HIS CURRENT POSTING HE
SERVED AS POLICY ADVISER TO THE
DEPUTY FOREIGN MINISTERS BASED
IN JERUSALEM.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS TWENTY
YEAR DIPLOMATIC CAREER COFFIN
HAS SERVED AS DEPUTY COUNSEL
GENERAL IN NEW YORK CITY.
CHIEF OF STAFF TO AMBASSADORS IN
WASHINGTON DC.
DEPUTY AMBASSADOR IN THAILAND
AND DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL IN
SHANGHAI.
AS WELL AS SERVING IN MANY
DOMESTIC FOREIGN MINISTRY
POSITIONS.
MEMBERS AS WE FULLY KNOW ISRAEL
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE LONG SHARED A
PRODUCTIVE IN BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIP.
BILL TOM PROMOTING DEMOCRACY AND
EXPANDING COOPERATION IN THE
AREAS OF TRADE.
WATER MANAGEMENT AGRICULTURE
CLIMATE CHANGE TECHNOLOGY AND
CULTURE.
IN FACT IN THE AREA OF
TECHNOLOGY CALIFORNIAN ISRAEL
ARE CREATING HUNDREDS OF TECH
COMPANIES AND THOUSANDS OF JOBS
LOCATED HERE AND IN ISRAEL.
WHETHER IT'S SIGNING AMMO USER
OBSERVING THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
OR WORKING TO PROVIDE DISASTER
RELIEF TO VICTIMS.
WE SHARE A DEEP BOND.
I HAVE NO DOUBT ISRAEL IN
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO BE
EVER GROWING PARTNERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
CONSUL GENERAL OF ISRAEL'S LEMME
KAUFMAN
.
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE WE'VE BEEN JOINED ON
THE FLOOR BY A FORMER MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE THE HONORABLE
KEVIN MURRAY HAS JOINED US ON
THE FLOOR CARRIES.
AND I BELIEVE DOCTOR CHOI HAS
GAS ON THE FLOOR WITH US TODAY
DOCTOR CHOI FROM MY DESK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SAW I RISE TODAY. TO
INTRODUCE SPECIAL GUESTS.
WHO ARE OF P. ERA TO COMMEMORATE?
THE ONE HUNDRED YEARS OF OUR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE MARCH FIRST
MOVEMENT IN KOREA.
AND TO WITNESS AT THE ASSEMBLY
OF PROCLAMATION.
OF OUR MARCH FIRST OR SO YOU
WANNA SO IN DAY. TO REMEMBER
EIGHT PATRIA.
WHILE THE RESOLUTION NO ORDER
THE ON THE FLOOR --
THIS THURSDAY.
MARCH FIRST MOVEMENT IS A WIDELY
RECOGNIZED AS IT'S FROM THE
JAPANESE SO COLONIAL OCCUPATION
OF THE COUNTRY.
AND IS A CELEBRATED TO TODAY BY
ALL KOREANS SO AROUND THE WORLD.
A YOUNG KOREAN WOMAN --
BY THE NAME OF WHAT YOU ONE SOON
IS UP BEST KNOWN AS AN ORGANIZED
SO OF THE MARCH FIRST.
MOVEMENT.
AND THE BETWEEN MARCH FIRST AND
APRIL ELEVENTH OF ONE NINETEEN
NINETY IN.
ULTIMATELY TOOL MILLION KOREANS
PARTICIPATED IN MORE THAN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DEMONSTRATIONS
SELL FOR INDEPENDENTS.
WHILE THE MOVEMENT THAT DID NOT
TO DELIVER THE INDEPENDENCE ARE
FOR KOREANS AT THAT TIME.
IT DID STOP THE STRUGGLE AND IS
A RECOGNIZED AS THE BEGINNING OF
THE INDEPENDENCE OF MOVEMENT
TODAY.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HAVING THE
LARGEST A KOREAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THIS TO MOVE MONTHS.
OF DOT OFF OVER GREATER
SIGNIFICANCE SO TO THE KOREAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
IT IS OUT WITH THIS HONOR ON THE
HUNDREDS SO.
ANNIVERSARY ON I DOUBT I
INTRODUCED ON THIS GAS.
THOUGH IN THE CHAMBER OF FALL ON
THE GALLERY ON MY LAPTOP UP
THERE IF YOU CAN RISE SO.
LET ME BRIEFLY --
INTRODUCE OUR MISTER STOCKTON
THE PRESIDENT OF OF KOREANS OF
US ALL FOR WESTERN UNITED STATES.
TONE YUN.
A PRESIDENT OF A SAN FRANCISCO
KOREAN ASSOCIATION YOUNG HOLD
PARKER PRESIDENT OF A KOREAN --
BORDER WITH DIRECTORS OF A SAN
FRANCISCO LX OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO KOREAN AMERICAN --
BOARD WITH DIRECTOR SO.
AND NUMBER OF PEOPLE FROM
SACRAMENTO.
OF THE FEDERATION OF A KOREAN
AMERICANS SO EMAIL ON JUL AND
SOME WHILE --
ON HANNAH YOU SOME HOLE THE OWN
GOAL SO TOM J. IN THIS OP OR
LOCKED IN AND THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO.
OF KOREAN CONSERVE US TURN ON
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
THROUGH THIS CHAMBER IN
HONORABLE YOU ONCE AND DAY AND
IN COMMEMORATING.
THE ONE HUNDREDTH SO --
YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE MARCH
FIRST MOVEMENT OF FOR KOREAN
INDEPENDENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEM
THANK
YOU MEMBERS I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE A FORMER MEMBER OF
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THE SENATE ROD RIGHT HAS
JOINED US IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBERS.
MISTER RIGHT
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GUEST
WITH US IN THAT CHAMBER.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE UP I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH US TODAY
[inaudible]
IS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD. TO HAVE IN THE AUDIENCE
AND TO PRESENT A RESOLUTION
TODAY TO SEE T. TURNING AN
ATTORNEY FOR A NEW WAY OF LIFE.
AND MICHAEL TOWER WHO IS IN THE
GALLERY WHO IS CO DIRECTOR OF A
NEW WAY OF LIFE.
AND AS WAS JUST INTRODUCED MR AS
SENATOR STATE SENATOR REID RIGHT
ALSO WITH A NEW WAY OF LIFE RE
ENTRY PROJECT.
AT A NEW WAY OF LIFE HAS
RESIGNED PROVIDED SAFETY SUPPORT
AND PLACES TO LIVE. FOR MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WOMEN IN THEIR
CHILDREN I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SUSAN BURTON A
FOUNDER OF NEW WAY AND LOTS OF
LIFE WHO WAS HONORED.
AS ONE OF SEE AN IN HEROES FOR
HER WORK IN THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS ALSO THE TEN YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF A NEW WAY OF LIFE
PRO BONO LEGAL CLINIC WHICH
TELLS FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE GAIN EMPLOYMENT.
BY EXPANDING THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORDS SO THAT THEY CAN OBTAIN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES AND THE
WORK THAT THEY DO AT A NEW WAY
OF LIFE WAS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I ASKED TO CHAIR SELECT
COMMITTEE.
ON INCARCERATED WOMEN TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT AND SHOWCASE THE KINDS
OF WAYS WE CAN BE SUPPORTIVE OF
WOMEN ONCE THEY ARE RE ENTERING
INTO LIFE.
AFTER THEIR TIME AWAY PLEASE
JOIN ME MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IN ACKNOWLEDGING AND
SUPPORTING A NEW WAY OF LIFE AND
C. T. TOURNEY.
AND MICHAEL TOWER THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION MEMBERS
MISTER MEDINA FROM MY DESK IN
THE REAR CHAMBER THIS MEDINA.
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE AS PART OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS.
AND AS CHAIR OF THE FOREIGN
DIGNITARIES COMMITTEE OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS.
I RISE TO INTRODUCE MISTER ME
AGAIN FLORIDA.
THE FIRST SECRETARY OF THE
EMBASSY OF THE REPUBLIC OF CUBA.
IN WASHINGTON DC.
CUBA THIS YEAR WILL BE
CELEBRATING ITS FIVE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FOUNDING OF
THE CITY OF HAVANA.
I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS TO SAY HELLO.
AND LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION OF CUBA.
THAT WAS ADOPTED YESTERDAY.
MISTER FRAGA IS ACCOMPANIED BY
MISTER BILL CAMP.
IN THE GALLERY.
AND MISS NANCY YAMADA.
ROSS MYERS WHO ARE WITH THE
BUILDING RELATIONS WITH CUBAN
LABOR.
AND ARE SEATED IN THE GALLERY.
THE BUILDING RELATIONS WITH THE
CUBAN LABOR MOVEMENT WORKS TO
IMPROVE.
AND STRENGTHEN RELATIONS BETWEEN
THE UNITED STATES AND CUBA.
I LIKE MANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THIS HOUSE HAD THE PLEASURE TO
TRAVEL TO CUBA.
AND HOPE TO DO SO AGAIN.
WHILE CONTINUING OUR EFFORTS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH CUBA.
THANK YOU TO THE FIRST SECRETARY
AND WELCOME AGAIN PLEASE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY MR
BEGAN FARRAGO
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND MISTER
FRAZIER.
I BELIEVE MISTER FRAZIER HAS GAS
IN THE CHAMBER MISTER FRAZIER
RECOGNIZE FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MY COLLEAGUES AND I FROM SOLANO
MERCED AND SO WE CAN COUNTIES.
ARE PLEASED TO INTRODUCE OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
WHO ARE DOING SUCH IMPORTANT
WORK FOR ALL OF OUR CHILDREN AT
THE PARENT LEADERSHIP TRAINING
INSTITUTE?
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE PARENT LEADERSHIP.
TRAINING INSTITUTE IS A PARENT
LED ORGANIZATION.
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE
LIFELONG HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE HERE TODAY TO OBSERVE
THEIR GOVERNMENT AT WORK.
THE CHAPTERS IN SOLANO SAN
JOAQUIN IN MERCED PL TI IS A
TWENTY WEEK.
EVIDENCE BASED CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
DURING THESE TWENTY WEEKS
PARENTS LEARN HOW TO BECOME
LEADERS IN AGENTS OF CHANGE.
THROUGH A CURRICULUM THAT
DEVELOPS.
DEMOCRACY SKILLS.
PARENTS HAVE DEDICATED OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOURS IN
TRAINING COMMUNITY PROJECTS
WHILE WORKING WITH LOCAL
STATEWIDE REPRESENTATIVES.
ALL WITH THE GOAL OF CREATING
POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL
CHILDREN. TWO HUNDRED PARENTS
HAVE GRADUATED. TO BECOME
LEADING ADVOCATES FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
THANK YOU FOR THE WONDERFUL WORK
THAT THEY DO.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO STAY STRONG
AS YOU CONTINUE YOUR GOOD WORK.
MY COLLEAGUES A LOOK FORTY
HEARING.
MORE FROM YOU AS I GROW AS YOU
GROW YOUR CALL COALITION EVEN
LARGER.
COLLEAGUES UP IN THE GALLERY
WOULD YOU PLEASE WELCOME.
PTO I
EN MIS READ US YOU HAVE
GUESTS MS REAVIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM THRILLED TO WELCOME
UP IN THE GALLERY THE FED NOT
DANIEL TO TABI M. BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS WERE VISITING
TODAY FROM MY DISTRICT.
THE TO TABI I'M HAVE LIVED IN
THE VALLEYS SURROUNDING LOS
ANGELES FOR OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
YEARS.
THE TO TAVIA MAINTAIN TRIBAL
GOVERNANCE THROUGH THE SPANISH
MEXICAN AND AMERICAN COLONIAL
PERIODS AND CONTINUE TO GOVERN
THEMSELVES TO THIS DAY.
THE FERNANDO INYO TO TABI I'M
BAND OF MISSION IS SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WHICH THEY PRESERVE
CELEBRATE AND AND RICH THROUGH
THEIR TRIBAL CULTURAL TO TOP EM
DAYS.
AN ANNUAL CELEBRATION OF SINGING
AND DANCING MONTHLY CULTURAL
WORKSHOPS TO SHARE SONGS AND
DANCES.
AND A LANGUAGE INITIATIVE TO
CREATE A COLORING BOOK FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND A THIRD GRADE
WORKBOOK FOR LOCAL AREA YOUTH.
TO REPRESENT THE FOR NON THEY
KNOW TO TABI I'M BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING TRIBAL PRESIDENT RUDY
ORTEGA JUNIOR THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEMS WANTING TO PASS
RETAIN.
SAYS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE ACR TWENTY FOUR BY MR
STONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
MARK STONE RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTING AND
CASHING WEEK.
MISTER STONE ON THE RESOLUTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ACR TWENTY FOUR
ESTABLISHES NATIONAL COURT
REPORTING AND CAPTIONING WEEK
THIS IS AN INITIATIVE THAT WE
RUN EVERY YEAR. TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANT WORK THE COURT
REPORTERS AND CAPTION OR IS DUE
FOR OUR COURT PROCEEDINGS AND
OTHER OFFICIAL PROCEEDINGS
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE MOST COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
RECORD WE NEED TO BE RELYING ON
COURT REPORTERS WHO ARE IN
COURTROOMS DATE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT WHERE WE CAN AFFORD THEM
WE'VE RUN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
INITIATIVES RECENTLY TO ENSURE
THAT WE GET ADEQUATE COURT
REPORTING IN OUR COURTROOMS AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL ARE
FALLING SHORT.
CAP CENTERS PROVIDE THE
CAPTIONING OF OFFICIAL.
PROCEEDINGS EVEN ENTERTAINMENTS
NEWS AND ALL TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
WHAT THEY'RE READING WITH THIS I
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON A C. R.
TWENTY FOUR AND I ASK THAT THE
FIRST ROLE.
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
MR STARR IS ASSN THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE THERE
SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MR STONE WE
RETURNED TO YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER UP IN THE GALLERY UP TO
MY RIGHT ALTHOUGH I DON'T.
I HOPE THEY'RE STILL THERE I
CAN'T SEE THEM UP THERE FROM THE
DEPOSITION REPORTERS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE CHARLOTTE MATHIAS.
CAM BECAUSE YOUR BECAUSE YOUR
AREA AND BARBARA COMO.
AND FROM THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION RATE
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM SEVENTY
WELCOME.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR THIS IS A C. R. TWENTY
SEVEN CORKERY.
IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION TWENTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
ANOTHER SHOWS IT'S A BUYER
RUSSIAN.
THIS CARILLO ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THERE ARE NUMEROUS UNTIL
STORIES THE CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS
AND IT'S AND IT'S OUR PRIVILEGE
AS LEGISLATORS TO BRING THESE
CHAMPIONS TO LIGHT.
MY CONSTITUENTS AND COMMUNITY
ACTIVISTS LAUREN BUSAN FROM THE
FIFTY FIRST AND I CONNECTED WHEN
WE MET AT OUR DISTRICTS COFFEE
MEETING IN ECHO PARK LAST
OCTOBER.
SHE HAS MADE IT HER MISSION. TO
RECOGNIZE BEAR RESIDENTS LEGACY
THROUGH A U. S. POSTAGE STAMP
CAMPAIGN.
BEAR RESIDENTS NAME IS LARGELY
VACANT FROM OUR HISTORY BOOKS.
BUT HE MERITS PROPER RECOGNITION.
HE WAS AN UNSUNG HERO OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WHO FOUGHT
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE.
AN LGBT Q. VISIBILITY.
IN ATIME.
WHICH THAT WAS NOT VERY POPULAR.
BORN IN NINETEEN TWELVE HE WAS A
LIFELONG BELIEVER IN CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE.
AND THE TEACHINGS OF MOHAMMED
GANDHI.
WHICH LATER BECAME A FIXTURE OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
DURING THE NINETEEN FIFTIES HE
BECAME A CLOSE ADVISER AND
FRIEND. TO DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR INTRODUCING DR KING.
TO GANDHI'S TEACHINGS.
RUSTIN THEN BECAME THE CHIEF
ORGANIZER OF THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE AND HE WAS
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON THE JOB
TO FREEDOM PIPELINE.
RUSTIN READ THE TEN GOALS ON THE
STEPS OF THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL IN
FRONT OF TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AT THE MARCH.
THESE GOALS INCLUDING.
INCLUDED THE SEGREGATING ALL
SCHOOLS.
BANNING HOUSING DISCRIMINATION.
AN INCREASING THE MINIMUM WAGE
ALL ISSUES WHICH CONTINUE TO BE
PREVAIL AND TO THIS GOVERNING
BODY.
BEAR RUSTIN WAS AHEAD OF HIS
TIME BY CHAMPIONING LABOR EQUITY
AN ISSUE THAT CONTINUES TO BE
PRESENT IN OUR SOCIETY.
AND AN ISSUE THAT I AND MANY
MANY OF US WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON ON THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE.
THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE MUST
CONTINUE IF WE ARE TO TRULY
HONOR THOSE WHO CAME BEFORE US.
AUSTIN IS A FIGURE WHO REMAIN
WHO RESEMBLES MANY PEOPLE FROM
MY DISTRICT IN ACROSS THE STATE
WHO FACE COMPOUNDING
DISCRIMINATION DUE TO THEIR RACE.
AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
IT IS FITTING.
THAT DURING BLACK HISTORY MONTH
THE LEGISLATURE.
SHOULD RECOGNIZE HIS TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND THE FIRST CALL BE OPEN
FOR ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MISS CREE OF DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AYE TO RISE A DAY IN SUPPORT OF
A C. R. TWENTY SEVEN AND THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IS PROUD PROUD TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE BAY
RUSTIN.
AS A TRUE CIVIL RIGHTS HERO AND
A FIGHTER FOR JUSTICE.
YOU PROBABLY CAN READ ABOUT THE
BY -- OF OF
OF RUSTIN IN TERMS OF HIS
EDUCATION HIS FAMILY WAS WELL
KNOWN HE BASICALLY ATTENDED
WILBERFORCE UNIVERSITY AS WELL
AS CHENEY STATE UNIVERSITY TO
BLACK COLLEGES.
WAS VERY SHARP VERY SMART.
YOU SHOULD REMEMBER HIM AS A MAN
WHO TRULY BELIEVE IN THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE TALK ABOUT CIVIL
RIGHTS.
THE TALK ABOUT EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
IN ACCESS.
BAYARD RUSTIN PUT HIMSELF ALWAYS
ON THE LINE FOR JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY.
EVEN AS A STUDENT WILBERFORCE.
HE BASICALLY WAS KICKED OUT OF
WILBERFORCE UNIVERSITY BECAUSE
HE ORGANIZED A PROTEST AND A
STRIKE AT THIS COLLEGE.
HE TALKED ABOUT JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY EVERYWHERE HE WENT.
HE ACTUALLY SPENT TWO YEARS IN
PRISON BECAUSE HE WAS A
CONSCIENTIOUS OBJECTOR TO WORLD
WAR.
TWO HE WAS A MAN WHO WAS A
PACIFIST WHO BELIEVE IN THE
PRINCIPLES OF GANDHI NOT JUST IN
SOME ABSTRACT SENSE WITHIN A
REAL PRACTICAL SINCE.
HE BELIEVED IN EQUALITY OF
EVERYONE.
HE WAS A GAY AFRICAN AMERICAN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND WHICH MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
HIM TO FUNCTION NOT ONLY IN THE
LARGER SOCIETY BUT EVEN WITHIN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
IN THE NINETEEN THIRTIES AND
FORTIES IN WHICH SHE LIVED.
YET DESPITE THAT HE BECAME A
BELOVED FRIEND.
OF THURGOOD MARSHALL AND SO MANY
OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS.
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT HE
WAS TRULY AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT IT
IS TO BE A PERSON TOTALLY
COMMITTED TOOK EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE BAYARD RUSTIN
OFTEN WAS IN THE BACKGROUND OF
MOVEMENTS WHETHER IT WAS THE
MARCH ON WASHINGTON OR VARIOUS
OTHER KINDS OF PROTEST.
HE'S STILL AT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME HE WASN'T AFRAID TO TELL
YOU WHO HE WAS.
BUT HE RECOGNIZE IT PROBABLY HIS
PRESENCE IN A VERY VISIBLE SENSE
WOULD HAVE HAD AN ADVERSE EFFECT
ON THE MARCH HAD AN ADVERSE
EFFECT ON THE MOVEMENT.
AND SO HE VOLUNTARILY STEPPED
THIS TO TAKE THE FRONT SEAT
WHILE HE WORKED BEHIND THE
SCENES.
HE IS TRULY A HERO IN EVERY
SENSE OF THE WORD HAVING
SACRIFICE AND SUFFERED THROUGH
MANY OF THE PROTEST THAT EXISTED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
HE DIED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS A
PERSON WHO AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
FIVE AND THE NEW YORK TIMES
TALKED ABOUT LOOKING BACK AT A
BAD RUSTIN AS A QUAKER.
AND THEY SAID THE PRINCIPAL
FACTORS WHICH INFLUENCE HIS LIFE
WAS NONVIOLENT TACTICS
CONSTITUTIONAL MEANS DEMOCRATIC
PROCEDURES RESPECT FOR HUMAN
PERSONALITY AND A BELIEF THAT
ALL PEOPLE ARE.
ONE WE HAVE VERY FEW PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MADE THE KIND OF SACRIFICE
THAT BARED RUSTIN DID WITHOUT
DEMANDING ATTENTION WITHOUT
DEMANDING THAT THINGS HAD TO BE
A REFLECTION OF HIM.
BUT OPENING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE
BRACES RESOLUTION WE ALSO ASKED
THAT WE ALSO LOOK VERY CAREFULLY
AT THE THE MOVEMENT THAT IS
BEING DESIGNED TO GET A STAMP IN
HIS HONOR.
THAT IT WILL MEAN A LOT FOR ALL
FOR THE MOVEMENT ITSELF AND FOR
THE DIVERSITY OF THIS COUNTRY TO
NOT ONLY TALK ABOUT DIVERSITY IN
TERMS OF RACE.
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF SEXUALITY.
WE'RE VERY ANA TODAY TO BE A
PART OF THIS I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES TO BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FOR IT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ACR.
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE TO LEND MY VOICE TO
THE TO THE CHORUS OF TALKING
ABOUT A BIGGER RESTAURANT I
THINK MY CALLING FOR LOS ANGELES
AND AND YOU SEEN DOCTOR WEBER --
FOR SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK HAWK HE CAUCUS.
WE ALSO HOLD BEEN ARRESTED IN IN
OUR HEARTS AS ONE OF OUR TRUE
HEROES.
FROM HIS TIME AS A YOUNG MAN
ORGANIZING UNTIL.
HIS DEATH HE WAS ACTIVE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF CIVIL RIGHTS JIM
CROW LAWS L. G. B. T. EQUALITY.
AND ALTHOUGH HIS WORK PUT HIM ON
THE AS A PROLIFIC ORGANIZER ON
THE ON THE STATURE OF MARTIN
LUTHER KING MAHATMA GANDHI HE
WAS PUSHED TO THE BACK BECAUSE
HE REFUSED TO LIVE HIS LIFE IN
THE SHADOWS.
HE REFUSED TO LIVE IN THE
BACKGROUND --
TO BE ABLE TO DO HIS WORK HE
COULD DO HIS WORK WITHOUT
GETTING ALL THE CREDIT --
HE DARED TO LIVE OUT LOUD WHEN
IT WAS BOTH ILLEGAL TO HAVE FULL
RIGHTS AS A AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
WHEN IT WAS OKAY TO BE DIAGNOSED
AS MENTALLY ILL. FOR BEING A
HOMOSEXUAL --
AS A YOUNG MAN HE SAW HIS DUTY
TO MULTIPLE TIME HE WOULD NOT
AND A BET.
BY LIVING IN A HE LIVED HIS
TERMS. TO COMBAT PREJUDICE.
IN ITS AGE TRULY SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN ALL LOOK FORWARD TO DO AS
HE RAISED HIS VOICE FOR DIGNITY.
FOR L. G. B. T. FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR EVERYTHING THAT HE
STOOD -- FOR
IT WAS FOR DIGNITY OF ALL AND
LET US ALL THINK MEMBERS AS WE
WERE FORWARD IN OUR WORK --
WHETHER IT'S END OF LIFE WORK
WHETHER IT'S AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WHETHER IT'S
AROUND ADDICTIONS THE BEST WE
CAN EVER DO IS TO LIVE IN THE
AY THAT WE PROVIDE AS TOO MUCH
DIGNITY.
AND HOPE AS WE CAN FOR EVERYBODY
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
WHERE THE TO PUT A STAMP ON AS
WE RECOGNIZE BEEN ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION MISS CREEL YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS WHO
SHARED.
YOUR THOUGHTS --
AND PASSION FOR THIS ISSUE WE
OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE WORD
INTERSECTION ALIKI.
I AM NEITHER PART OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS NOR MY A PART OF THE LGBT
Q. CAUCUS BUT WHAT I AM.
IS A PROUD AMERICAN WHO BELIEVES
THAT THESE UNSUNG HEROES HAVE
SHAPED US TO WHO WE ARE TODAY.
AND SO WITH THAT I AM ENCOURAGED
AND I AM BOTH GRATEFUL THAT THIS
RESOLUTION CAME TO LIGHT IN MY
OFFICE FROM A MEMBER OF MY
CONSTITUENCY.
AND THAT WE ARE SHEDDING LIGHT
WHERE THERE IS START I MAY I
WILL SHARE A QUICK QUOTE.
FROM THEIR RESTING WHO SAID LET
US NOT BE ENRAGED BY INJUSTICE.
BUT LET US NOT BE DESTROYED BY
IT.
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE AND THE STAMP COMMEMORATING
HIS LEGACY IS ONE STEP FORWARD
TO ENSURING THAT HE HAS
RECOGNIZED. FOR WHAT HE HAS DONE
AND WHAT HE CONTRIBUTED TO OUR
GREAT.
NATION SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
IN THIS CAREER WOULD YOU LIKE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS YES MISTER SPEAKER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
ON A C. R..
TWENTY SEVEN THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL.
IT'S WAS CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY
FIVE CO AUTHORS AT IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MS CARILLO BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER ADVOCATES ACROSS
THE NATION HAVE BEEN FIGHTING TO
COMMEMORATE BAYARD RUSTIN FOR US
POSTAGE STAMP.
MY CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY HAVE ENTIRELY
SUPPORTING THIS EFFORT PLEASE
HELP ME RECOGNIZE LAUREN WHOSE
SON WHO IS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL.
TWO TWENTY I'M SORRY TWENTY TEN
AND IT'S ALSO THE WEST COAST
DIRECTOR OF THE BEAR RESIDENTS
STAND CAMPAIGN.
DEVIN MY MY PENSION WHO IS ALSO
HELPING AMPLIFY THEIR RESIDENTS
LIKE A SEE THROUGH FAITH BASED
OUT REGION ORGANIZING PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING LAUREN AND
DEVIN RESIDENTS OF MY HOME
DISTRICT.
WHO PROBABLY THIRD THE FIFTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AS
MEMBERS OF THE ECHO PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL THANK YOU?
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVED TO A
GERMANS IN MEMORY.
A COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS I
UNDERSTAND THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
MELENDEZ CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY
LAST WEEK PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING THIS MELENDEZ A HAPPY
BELATED BIRTHDAY.
NOT SURE WHAT THAT WAS.
MOVING FORWARD.
ALL MEMBERS MUST FILE THEIR
ANNUAL STATEMENT OF ECONOMIC
INTEREST FORMS BY FRIDAY MARCH
FIRST.
PLEASE NOTE THE FORM SEVEN
HUNDRED MUST BE SUBMITTED TO THE
CHIEF CLERK THAT'S ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY SIX BY FIVE PM.
THIS DEADLINE IS FOR MEMBERS
DESIGNATED STAFF MUST FILE.
THOSE FORMS BY APRIL FIRST
DISCUSSION SESSIONS SCHEDULE.
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SIX CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
AND THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE
AM.
AND THERE'S BREAKING NEWS THAT
IT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL'S
BIRTHDAY TODAY.
MISTER O'DONNELL [inaudible]
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
HE LOOKS GRUMPY ABOUT IT.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED.
CALLS NOT LIFTED.
AND MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. FOUR GERMAN TO MEMORY AND
PLEASE GIVE ME RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND SHERMAN IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
MR HOLDEN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TODAY.
TO ADJOURN AND MEMORY.
OF JOAN WILLIAMS.
A WOMAN OF GREAT COURAGE AND
GREG.
A MODEL OF CIVILITY IN THE FACE
OF ADVERSITY.
MS WILLIAMS IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN HAD THE DISTINCTION OF
BEING SELECTED.
AS A CITY OF PASADENA AS MISS
CROWN CITY.
AN HONOR THAT WAS TO INCLUDE A
TRIP DOWN COLORADO BOULEVARD.
ATOP THE CITY OF PASSAGES FLOAT
IN THE TERM A ROSE PARADE ON NEW
YEAR'S DAY.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HOWEVER
WHEN HER AFRICAN AMERICAN
HERITAGE WAS LEARNED SUDDENLY
THERE WAS NO FUNDS FOR THE FLOW
THAT YEAR.
AND SHE WAS DENIED THE HONOR.
ALMOST SIXTY YEARS LATER.
THE CITY OF PASADENA APOLOGIZE
AND THE TOURNAMENT OF ROSES
INVITED HER TO RIDE IN THE
200-015-0020 SIX ANNUAL ROSE
PARADE.
WITH THE THEME INSPIRING STORIES.
BECAUSE OF HER INSPIRING STORY.
I SELECTED MS WILLIAMS AS MY TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN UNSUNG HERO FOR
THE C. O. B. C. BLACK HISTORY
CELEBRATION.
MS WILLIAMS HAD A THIRTY TWO
YEAR CAREER WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE.
AND GAVE HER VOLUNTEER TIME TO
THE COMMUNITY AND MANY ENDEAVORS
INCLUDING PASADENA AIDS SERVICE
CENTER AND THE LINK SATURDAY
SCHOOL FOR PASADENA CHILDREN.
SHE PROCEEDED IN DEATH BY HER
HUSBAND OF FORTY FIVE YEARS BOB
WILLIAMS A PILOT WITH THE
TUSKEGEE AIRMAN.
THEY HAVE THREE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND SHE WILL BE SORELY MISSED.
THANK YOU THIS HOLDEN.
MR TANG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
KIRBY SIDE AND UNDER SHOCKING
CIRCUMSTANCES I RISE AND MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES IN SAN
FRANCISCO --
RISE TODAY TO JR IN THE MEMORY.
OF OUR PUBLIC DEFENDER JEFF
ADACHI.
HE'S CALIFORNIA'S ONLY A ELECTED
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN THE NATIVE
SACRAMENTO.
HE REALLY DEVELOPED HIS FIRST
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS PRIMARILY
THROUGH HIS FAMILY BACKGROUND
HIS PARENTS AND HIS GRANDPARENTS
WERE INTERNED.
DURING WORLD WAR TO LIKE SO MANY
OTHER.
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
AND WHILE HE HAS ALWAYS REMEMBER
TOOK THOSE LESSONS IT IS REALLY
ONCE HE GRADUATE FROM LAW SCHOOL.
STARTED WORKING IN THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE THAT HE WAS
REALLY ABLE. TO CONTINUE THAT
FIGHT FOR SOME AND HE WAS
SOMEONE WHO WAS ALWAYS KNOWN AS
A CHAMPION FOR THE UNDERDOG.
SOMEONE WHO GAVE VOICE TO THE
VOICELESS.
SOMEONE WHO ALWAYS STOOD FOR
WHAT WAS RIGHT NO MATTER WHAT
THE ODDS WERE NO MATTER.
WHAT THE CAUSE WAS NO MATTER THE
PUBLIC RIDICULE TO REALLY ONE OF
THE MOST AMERICAN PRINCIPLES
THAT EVERYBODY HAD A RIGHT?
TO DEFENSE IN THE COURT OF LAW
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT HE
DEMANDED OF HIMSELF.
SHE TRIED CASES HIMSELF HE
DIDN'T JUST.
BECOME AN ADMINISTRATOR WHEN HE
WAS ELECTED IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE HE REALLY
DEMANDS THAT ARE DEMANDED THAT
OF EVERY SINGLE ONE OF HIS
ATTORNEYS.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE STAFF IF
YOU HEAR.
JUST THE FEEDBACK FROM HIS
DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDERS FROM
PEOPLE WHO WORKED.
WITH HIM.
SHE NEVER ALLOWED IT TO BE AN
EXCUSE THAT.
HIS STAFF WERE PAID TO BE THESE
THESE LAWYERS THAT HE DEMANDED
THE VERY VERY BASS THAT OFFICE --
WAS REALLY USHERED INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY BY HIS
LEADERSHIP WASN'T JUST.
THE WAY HE FOUGHT THE WAY HE
FOUGHT IN COURT BROUGHT
TECHNOLOGY INTO THE OFFICE HE
DEMANDED METRICS FROM HIS
LAWYERS HE DEMANDED.
THAT THEY WORK WITH HIS FAMILIES
AND TALK TO THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS WAS SOMEBODY WHO.
REALLY WASN'T JUST. ONE OF THE
BEST DEFENSE ATTORNEYS YOU'RE
FROM MAD REALLY. ONE OF THE BEST
PEOPLE YOU EVER MET --
IN ADDITION IT'S A HUGE LOSS FOR
OUR ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY SHE
WAS OUR ONLY A JAPANESE AMERICAN
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
ABOUT ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
ASIAN AMERICAN WITH OFFICIALS IN
THE CITY AS WELL AS IN OUR STATE
HE I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE FOUND
THE SPARE TIME BUT HE ALSO HAD A
HUGE INTEREST IN THE ARTS.
HE WAS A DOCUMENTARY FILMMAKER
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO ASIAN
AMERICAN STEREOTYPES IN THE
MEDIA --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
STILL GRAPPLING WITH WE WERE ALL
SHOCKED BY THE NEWS LATE.
FRIDAY NIGHT I KNOW HIS OFFICE
HAS A VIGIL AND FRONT OF THEIR
LOBBY. FOR HIM AND IT IS
SOMETHING INCREDIBLY.
HEAVY HEART THAT WE ASK YOU TO
RETURN.
THIS ASSEMBLY IN HIS MEMBER
TODAY ARE HARM YOUR PRAYER
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE GOING
OUT TO HIS WIFE.
NOT MITSUKO IN HIS DAUGHTER
LAUREN WHO HE LEAVES BEHIND BUT
IT'S REALLY NOT JUST HAPPEN.
HE I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU HOW BIG
OF FOR IT HE LEAVES BEHIND IN
OUR CITY.
BECAUSE HE WAS ALWAYS THAT
ADVOCATE WENT WHETHER IT WAS
BILL REFORM WHETHER IT WAS
REDUCING RECIDIVISM WHAT THERE
IS -- POLICE
REFORM ON THE ALL THE ISSUES
THAT I KNOW ARE TIMES ARE NOT
THE EASIEST POLITICAL ISSUES TO
DEAL WITH.
HE WAS THERE ON THE FRONT LINES
THAT HE WASN'T EVER SHOT ABOUT
STANDING UP FOR WHAT WAS RIGHT.
ON BECAUSE HE WAS A DOCUMENTARY
FILMMAKER HE ALWAYS HAD A TV
CREW WITH THEM WHICH IS KIND OF
ON HALF THE FUN OF BEING WITH
AND THAT YOU KNOW I'M GONNA MISS
THEM -- I
CAN REMEMBER HIS --
INCREDIBLE CAMPAIGN IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO BUT IS REALLY I'M
GONNA JUST MISSED HIS INCREDIBLE
ZF'S OF LIFE HE LIVED LIFE TO
THE FULL SENATE THE CONSTANT
MEMORY.
THAT -- WE
YOU KNOW LIFE IS SHORT AT THAT
POINT THAT HE SET THE EXAMPLE
SET THE BAR HIGH FOR ALL OF US
SO WITHOUT.
I RESPECTFULLY HOUSES TO INTERN
THE MEMORY OF FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER TANG MISS DAVID CHIU YOUR
ALSO RECOGNIZE OFFICER GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I JOIN MY WEBSITE COLLEAGUE --
IN THIS.
ADJOURNMENT WE DO A LOT OF THE
GERMAN IN MEMORIES.
FOR OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS WHO
HAVE LED LONG AND FULL LIVES AND
SO SADLY SO TRAGICALLY TODAY --
IT IS AN ADJOURNMENTS ABOUT
SOMEONE WHOSE GREATNESS WAS CUT
SHORT.
OUR COLLEAGUE SAID MUCH ABOUT --
MISTER DACHI WHAT I WILL SHARE
IS I REMEMBER THE VERY DAY I MET
HIM.
IT WAS IN THE COURT ROOM.
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO HALL OF
JUSTICE I WAS A YOUNG PROSECUTOR.
AND IN WALKED THIS LITERAL FORCE
OF NATURE.
I REMEMBER TURNING TO A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE AND SAYING WHO
IS THAT MAN.
HE WAS SOMEONE WHO EXUDED JUST
INCREDIBLE ENERGY.
PASSION AND AND THE FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE AND OVER THE YEARS --
I HAD CASES WITH HIM.
I GOT TO WORK ALONGSIDE WITH HIM
ON MANY FIGHTS --
WE ALL DID [inaudible]
AND HE WAS SOMEONE WHO.
WAS A CHAMPION NOT JUST FOR THE
ACCUSED.
BUT FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY FOR OUR CHILDREN
FOR ARE.
UNDOCUMENTED.
AND HE ALSO LED NOT JUST A SAN
FRANCISCO PROGRESSIVE MOVEMENT
BUT A STATEWIDE AND AND NATIONAL
PROGRESSIVE MOVEMENT. FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. FOR
ENDING CASH BAIL FOR ENSURING
THAT WERE FINALLY REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AGAIN.
REMINDING ALL OF US THAT THERE
BUT FOR THE GRACE OF GOD COULD
BE ANYONE WHO IS ACCUSED OF A
CRIME.
IN OUR SOCIETY.
AND AS FILL TING JUST SAID JEFF
WAS LEADER NOT JUST IN THE
CRIMINAL CONTEXT BUT IN THE ARTS
COMMUNITY IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
COMMUNITY.
PUSHING FOR THE ASIAN AMERICAN
HE IS AND WAS TRULY ONE OF A
KIND AND SO OUR HEARTS GO OUT.
NOT JUST TO HIS WIFE AND HIS
DAUGHTER BUT TO HIS EXTENDED
FAMILY OF COMMUNITY.
WARRIORS.
WE WERE ALL CHANGE BECAUSE OF
JEFF ADACHI.
REST IN POWER BROTHER.
THANK YOU MISS YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI IRAQIS ARE MUCH I
WANT TO THANK OF MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAM CISCO. FOR HONORING.
JEFF ADACHI IN I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF MEETING JEFF ADACHI
WAY BACK IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES DURING THE REDRESS
MOVEMENT THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
REDRESS MOVEMENT FOR A FOR
REDRESS AND REPARATIONS FOR THE
INCARCERATION.
OF JAPANESE AMERICANS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO AND YOU KNOW.
EVER SINCE THEN TO MEET.
JEFF ADACHI WAS THE COMMUNITY HE
GREW UP IN J. TOWN YOU KNOW HE
HE TOOK THAT ANGER OF THE
WARTIME INCARCERATION AND AND
NOT ONLY CHANNELED INTO CIVIL
RIGHTS BUT ALSO.
YOU KNOW HE HE HELP SO MANY
PEOPLE THROUGH GROUPS LIKE.
J. C. Y. SEE THE JAPANESE
COMMUNITY YOUTH COUNCIL HELPING.
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT WERE
YOU KNOW BLOW --
OF OF OF OF THE LAW AND I I
THINK HE TOOK --
THAT I LOVE FOR THE COMMUNITY --
AND AND AND CHANNEL IT INTO HIS
PASS AND I YOU KNOW ACT AS A
FORMER PROSECUTOR I CAN'T SAY
THAT I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT HE STOOD.
FOR BUT HE WAS ONE RIGHTEOUS
TRIAL LAWYER --
AND A BOAT AHEAD THAT MADE US
ALL PROUD.
AND MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANNA.
THANK IN OFFER CONDOLENCES TO
MIKE -- TO
OUR COLLEAGUES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND A COMMUNITY --
THAT'S HURTING RIGHT NOW I'VE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF MY FRIENDS
AND THE DEFENSE BAR --
AS SOMEONE THAT WORKED AS A
DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER OF PRO
LEVIN YEARS AND GOT TO FIRST TO
MEET AND NO.
AYE JEOPARDIZE SHE IN THAT ROLE
ODD TO SAY THAT HE IS A LEGEND --
HE IS HE WAS LARGE THE LIFE HE
SPOKE TO TO POWER HE REMINDED US
WHY WE DID WHAT WE DID BUT WE DO
WHAT WE DO.
AS PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
AND HE INSPIRED AND MEN TOWARD
AS BUSY AS HE WAS HUNDREDS UPON
HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS OF
YOUNGER ATTORNEYS.
AND HE TRULY TRULY --
MOBILE BE REMEMBER NOT JUST. FOR
WHO HE WAS.
BUT HE IS GONNA BE REMEMBERED
FOR GENERATIONS BECAUSE OF THE
CHAMPIONS IN THE WAR YEARS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE FOLLOWING IN HIS
FOOTSTEPS.
AND OFTENTIMES PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE AS AN
ELECTED PUBLIC DEFENDER IT'S AN
OUTLIER AND I WOULD OFTEN SAY
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW BUT ONE ELECTED
PUBLIC DEFENDER ANY OTHER COUNTY.
I DON'T KNOW BUT ONE OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER OTHER TO JAVA
DOT SHE A BECAUSE THAT THAT'S
HOW.
MUCH OF A CHAMPION HE WAS FOR
THE VOICELESS. FOR THOSE THAT.
NEEDED TO BE LIFTED UP AND
EMPOWER ABSOLUTELY REST IN POWER
AND I OFFER CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY AND THE ENTIRE SAN
FRANCISCO.
OF LEGAL COMMUNITY AND BEYOND
THAT IS HURTING RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL OF ALL REQUESTS TO
RETURN A MEMORY.
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN A MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SINGER NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY.
TWENTY EIGHT AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED